the more you study the war on drugs the
more absurd it seems to be what the
malla
is a country that has everything to
offer to be a peaceful wonderful and
progressive country but let me tell you
a story last year a friend of my kids he
had studied at TCU great student
he had become unknown very well on to
her professors and they liked her and
mind her
she had done some work on international
relations and then she went to study at
LSE ambassadors and she was thinking to
herself well what what should I do
should I come back to - what Amala and
do something for my country which he had
doubts he was afraid of how things were
going in what Amana or should I stay and
make a living for myself outside well
she decided to come back and in the
process of actually taking that decision
as a young lady
they like to Walt went partying they
were having some after night tacos in
something not far away from here and
unfortunately she happened to be in the
middle of a shooting between drug lords
and one other loose bullets cut her cut
her head and she died instantly
so this story I'm telling it was
somebody then especially my kids knew
very well but this happens in what Amana
all too often more than 5,000 deaths a
year well the war on drugs in what
Amanda certainly has destabilized the
country if you think about the numbers
you'll get an idea why
I was reading not long ago and a piston
wire that hit the hand times a study on
how much what what is the value of the
market value of the cocaine that that
goes from Colombia to Mexico which today
nowadays most of it about ninety percent
goes through what Amana it didn't used
to be that way because they used to go
in the Caribbean but once the DEA and
the United States decided to attack the
Caribbean trafficking it was all brought
inland to Central America and especially
what a man now
that amount of cocaine represent forty
billion dollars a year from Colombia to
northern Mexico this is before entering
the US market well that number alone is
about the size of the whole economy of
Guatemala so how can we have strong
institutions that will be able to
curtail the corruption behind all that
money I cannot give you exact data and I
don't have feel that on this but this is
something that what Imams talk about how
much the police or how much some of the
courts had been infiltrated with drug
money's and not only there even
political parties
but I don't blame them I blame the war
on drugs in the United States - what is
happening here in Guatemala because if
you wouldn't if the states would not be
confronting this war all these drug
lords would not have the amount of money
that they had the damage that the war on
drugs has done in Latin America
especially on Mexico and Guatemala and
Honduras and El Salvador and let's say
Colombia is much higher in terms of
innocent lives lost in terms of economic
in efficiencies in terms of
institutional corruption it's much
higher than the worst thing that you can
imagine in Iraq or Afghanistan if your
stance on the war on drugs is because a
vertical reasons then the more so you
should be against it why because the
more you should be responsible for your
own life and those of your kids don't
delegate that to the US government be
responsible yourself for ethical reasons